which one your mother is coming in so
never accept the limitations of someone
else you have to start with the belief
that you can do something
get your punk ass up off the couch and
get out to that guy dig me out of pain
we are born and you can't commit to this
you Ct Fletcher is here so the
competition for all intensive purposes
for you is over
never ever sex if you give me everything
you got
Oh any bitter you cannot man she soon
away and she good huh yourself across
that finish line he's a pilot from Long
Beach California he's a six-time world
champion power lifter he co-owns
Metroflex Jim Long Beach where he trains
he's Ct Fletcher and here his top ten
rules for success which one who mother
is this coming sir ha ha ha you didn't
think I was gonna do it did
you thought oh he's I'm staying in I
know he gonna say mother i fooled you I
hold you to my to thine own self be true
so to myself I had to be true
I'm not going litter it because litter
about conversation with mother as I
usually do if you know anything about me
I'm gonna limit him I'm gonna limit
maybe twelve thirteen months through the
whole thing because I would like
possibly to get a few seconds on see any
but if I don't make it
listen up question question for yourself
what is impossible never accept the
limitations of someone else somebody
told you that it's impossible don't even
try give up before you even try it for
yourself never accept the goddamn
limitation that someone else is placed
upon you decide for yourself what is
your limitation try it you son of a try
it for yourself
dad that is the only way the only way to
know if you can or can't do something I
gave it a try that's how I know get your
punk ass in there and give it a try the
most important thing is it is this right
here you must have and you have to start
with the belief that you can do
something I mean when we set out to go
to the moon some airhead had to believe
that we can build this goddamn rocket
ship they can take us to the moon
some song had to come up this I didn't
actually believe he could do it the
first you said you baby got a cam wheel
you know what is a better way of doing
this if I make this round I put through
sticks between I think we can roll
around a little faster the rest of the
caveman was looking at that song like it
was a hideous are you crazy
they don't never work but everyone for
that lunatic idiot we'd all be still
walking around so it has to be them it
says I believe we can do this be them
that has the new idea these who believe
that he can juice when all these other
idiots say you can't do it I want to be
that I want to beat him I said I
identified with him that was the first
introduced they innovated so when I was
invited here today and they said clever
I said to myself hmm I don't think my
approach in the industry that I am in
the fitness industry would be considered
clever because in this day and age this
time it's a push or a trend toward
easier is better
the easier way the easier approach 5
minute abs for millionaires
one minute now you don't think I'm
making this up
but I seem to add the other day for belt
you just put it around your waistline
and you can sit on your computer and
watch Netflix chat with your boyfriend a
girlfriend don't hear whatever it is you
talk to and it will work your abs for
you wow that's cool I just sit there
this machine will work my ass for me I
don't have to do one sit-up one crunch
goat 30 is code is not one not one and
here I come on old crush the old man 55
years old and I look you in the eyeballs
point my finger in your face now say
[ __ ] get your punk ass up off the couch
and get out to that goddamn G and work
for what you bought so I don't I don't
know if that will be considered clever
or not what do you think
hey is necessary it's a nice capable
it's no way out of pain we are born pain
is a must pain it is necessity of growth
be comfortable with being uncomfortable
pain is a necessary evil get used to it
make friends with it and then kick pains
ass and that way when it comes to take
you down and Buster dub I'm used to you
bring it on come on
paint sit your ass down and let's have
lunch together me and you pain let's do
it best bring your excuses
be committed and you can't commit to
this you if you don't know what total
commitment is if you don't know if you
don't want it that bad and if you have
made up in your mind yet enough into a
totally committee to let me kick your
ass and stay at home do us both a favor
just stay old bath at home sitting on
the couch you bye-bye with the little
[ __ ] dope house shoes on this is my
job that's what I like to do this what I
do I motivate some wannabe motivation
you don't want to be motivated leave you
room I rather die doing what I love to
do and sit at home talking about what I
should be doing
oh damn I one of these days I'm gonna
get up and do this oh I should go do
that you know I won't get a funny day
I'm gonna go to the gym I'm gonna
workout that I would rather die on the
bench pass or curling or squatting doing
what I love to do and talking about what
I might you over
[ __ ] dude that's the difference between
me and you I'm a dude it's talker I used
to walk into a competition and I would
say I am the one which one of you guys
is coming in second cuz all of you know
Ct Fletcher is here so the competition
for all intensive purposes for you is
over cuz first place yes that's mine
that's a guarantee that's a lock so you
can discuss amongst yourselves come to a
decision which one of y'all coming in
second and third that's okay with me
but this top podium that belongs to me
why because not one of you can I will me
you may have been born with more genetic
powers than I have but you can now out
determine me you came out real me you
can't out want me you can't outwork me
you can't out desire me I'm the king in
it and that's why this top spot this
number one that's mine you guys go ahead
fight over second and third but I know
coming from that type of a degree I
really felt like I was a strongest man
on the earth what you see here before
you today is leftovers I'm 55 every ball
my body ache
but I'm still seating mother but I'm big
enough I'm satisfied never ever become
satisfied satisfaction is the deathblow
it's the end of the line you cannot
progress farther than satisfaction
satisfaction is the end of your growth
it is the end of your journey it's over
for you
I am satisfied I no longer need to
struggle I no longer need to push myself
I'm done I have reached my goal
satisfaction am I satisfied not by a
long shot
ha it's my journey over no and I will
not go quietly until the night I will go
kicking and screaming satisfaction and
rich it is one thing I can't stand and
that's a edge and I'm gonna be a beast
oh you make the call it ain't help to me
it's up to you you don't be a salt
butter bean looking your whole entire
life you gotta carry
duh love to do some work man you've got
damn boot straps tight you gotta get to
tears in the gym and do so you gonna be
a hip having your whole entire life get
you minimizer long enough don't you
think it's time to do something about
that step through the looking-glass I'm
not giving you them Oh Alex tingle he'll
know
right now you bring that bottle this up
not something yeah don't let them if I
rule you it's a piece of issac anatomy
object you command back that's why I'm
number one cuz I'm willing to do what
you ain't willing to do all you want to
do is talk about what I'm doing but you
know what I'm doing something I got my
gas in it and I'm doing my best
that's all I ask any one of you into
here is to give me everything that you
got
if you give me everything you got Oh
every bitter you cannot fail
it's impossible for you to bake a bridge
untain your mind untain your mind from
the imprisonment of fear unchain your
mind
it's been encaged with doubt unchain
your mind lose yourself let yourself
free from the binds of average for the
rise of normal lose yourself from
intimidation let yourself free let your
mind go shift your focus your focus your
intensity your drive your everything
should be put into the amount the amount
of effort that you are going to put into
that attempt you cannot fail you cannot
fail if you give 100% of your efforts
you cannot fail
it is impossible there was a lady I
don't remember the lady's name but I
remember her act she came in absolutely
last in America everybody had crossed
the finish line she was the last person
in the stadium
the lights was getting dark and she fell
down 25 yards before the finish line but
that lady crawl she crawled people tried
to rush out and help her the medic came
out ready but she shooed him away she
shooed away and she dug herself across
that finish line back it's the kind of
attitude that I want you to have that's
what you focus on you focus on giving
that and everything you've got within
you every chop of energy every time for
strength every drop of intensity every
drop of testicular fortitude that I can
muster I'm gonna give it everything I
got
what is you always have power over the
amount of effort that you put into
whatever the Piron doing because you
know the only mission that I have the
only goal that I have the only
determination that I will make is that
I'm going to give this every goddamn
thing within me break the goddamn chains
break your chain let yourself be free go
out there and lay waste destroy some
I'm telling your mind
thank you so much for watching we made
this video because peel crashes - once
again if you have any famous
entrepreneurs that you want to sue
profile next please leave it in the
comment below we'd also love to know
which of CT Fletcher's top ten rules
meant the most to you hit you the
hardest leave in the comments below
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching to believe and we'll see
you soon
I'm coming from a position of being the
best at what I chose to do my chosen
field I was the best of day and the way
I approach being the best at that my
message travels throughout whatever
industry of whatever chosen field that
you choose what it whatever endeavor you
choose to take upon yourself if you want
to be the best at that if you want to
reach the pinnacle of that you must be
there's no way around you have to be
obsessed with obtaining that greatness
in any field greatness cannot be
achieved without obsession yeah I said
that I said it I said and I mean it I
stand on that if you want to be the best
you must be obsessed with it
he had a slide of a moment ago Orville
and Wilbur Wright do you think they
wouldn't obsessed with fine he fooling
yourself
they were obsessed with that JP Morgan
CEOs even talk-show host even anchor me
if you want to be the best anchorman you
must be you have no choice there's no
other way around is never easy way to do
it you have to be obsessed with that
can't get away from obsession my
recovery was taller
I prayed to God I told him if he's [ __ ]
gonna be like this much longer it just
take me out don't let me I don't want to
live like this I can't live like this
just let me die because this [ __ ] is
rough but you know what I didn't die I
kept living a doctor came in to me in
the hospital he said I heard CT two or
three times world 10 me I said yes
doctor I am and he said well he's shook
his head gun cocking [ __ ] his head and
he said man what happened to you I'll
tell you what I want to thank that
doctor but asking me what happened to me
he asked me what happened it was disdain
in his eyes he comes with me but I had
felt that far because I look like a
human skeleton he just couldn't believe
the CT what happened to you you don't
look like you ever lived away in your
whole life
but that doctor is what made me
determined to get back out there and a
climb back up to the top of the mountain
and be king of them beast once more
ah hey I thank you God you made me do
this ask me what happened you i'ma show
you ass for happy my mom you should tell
validation stick sometimes if you just a
little bit too high get a little full of
yourself you must be brought down you
will be talk less and I've seen now not
me she's why I don't care how bad you
are son
it's somebody else right there just a
little bit better I said now he'll know
mama somebody got me the badge
somebody got be these bad if you mama I
love you but that's me